would be an amateur if I could not sit
and pretend I do not understand the
motivations behind either side watch
what happened with Piers Morgan and
Andrew Tate what do you think of of what
Hamas did in October the 7th why are you
starting the story in the middle let me
ask you again it's a simple question do
you believe Hamas are a terror
organization and that's a very
interesting question but I think you're
pedaling Asin nities well just answer
the question can somebody do me a favor
Google asininity are they a terror group
you're pedaling Asin nities because I'll
tell you why Piers let me answer the
question of course you are simple
question going through a border on
October the 7th oh October the 7th
massacring young people at a festival
killing babies Oh killing babies that
was true well fine were the babies
vaccinated why are you being flippant
I'm not being flippant the point I am
making find that funny no but the point
I am making is that the media lies
firstly secondly what is your reaction
to what happened in October the 7th sure
I would be an amateur if I could not sit
and pretend I do not understand the
motivations behind either side I still
call the Israeli actions absolutely horr
and genocide okay in terms of what Hamas
did on October the 7th do you accept
that was an act of terrorism it's an
interesting question because it's not
really it very straightforward nothing
justifies what happened on October 7
what are they supposed to do nothing so
what are they supposed to do that was my
question for you is why can't you which
is my position on this is very
straightforward what Hamas did was an
act of Terror and to try and pretend
they're not makes you sound like Jeremy
Corbin I can't give a worse insult to
throw you right so I just want to ask
you one more time is what Hamas did on
October 7th an act of terrorism I think
pierce it is pedaling ass in entities
for you you sound like Jeremy Corbin no
let me answer the question 15 times he
refused to answer the question let me
the question you're now are they a
terror group or not they're one team's
freedom fighter and they are deemed a
terrorist what do you think I think that
if you lock people in an open air prison
and steal their land they're going to
retaliate so they're not a terror group
I think they're going to retaliate
they're not a terror group one team's
terrorist is now about eight are they a
terror group and also another thing I
want to make clear to you only Jeremy
Corbin has done this done what refused
to answer the question I think that what
they are doing is seemly deemed an act
of Terror by the people that the terror
these weasly words they're not weasly of
one more time is Hamas a terror group
who committed an act of terrorism I
think that when you lock people in an
open air prison you're going to have
retaliation no because I have to there's
me saying I think it's spineless sure as
a realist sometimes you do not come to
the conclusion of label good guys and
bad guys the world is not black and
white oh bad guys the world is not black
and white the world is actually very
gray anybody who sits and thinks there's
clear's
nothing no clown you are completely
wrong isn't it interesting Sunny host
it's so unfortunate we have to pick a
side right and then what did he say oh
the world is not black and white there
aren't good guys and bad guys this is
what the collapse of sanity and decency
and truth will do people will not know
whether murdering four-year-olds and 85y
olds and raping women in front of their
dying husbands whether that is good or
bad or whether there's any situation
when it is excusable he also of course
calls Gaza an open air prison and says
that they stole their land I might
remind you there has never been a
Palestinian State and before 1967 Gaza
was part of Egypt and before that it was
part of the British Empire and before
that it was part of the Ottoman Empire
and we can go back and back and back and
back and
back